[Music]
previously during the investigation ben
i'm so excited this is maybe the most
exciting thing
of the whole year same uh it came out of
nowhere a literal blessing in disguise
deadly premonition too
oh my god it is him it's punish york
oh my god that's a smash invite
joe look that's a smash invite right
there on his desk
oh my god i'm losing my mind
what the what i what it is
i was prepared for this
i need to go somewhere else oh
bravo sweary i love it oh god blessed
you
oh i need a breather i need to
i think i need to call my my mom
hello everybody we are back with more of
me and ben checking out
deadly premonition 2 i can't believe
we're playing the
2020s game of the year right here oh
it's happening
oh my god oh the loading screen had red
leaves now
i don't know if that was there before
but i just noticed it now
[Laughter]
swear you can't also put the two there
that's not
what that ah it's not i mean i'm not
gonna tell them how it works how it
doesn't work i trust my man
you can't have it both ways big words
i want to say it every time i'm really
excited about it
big word it's happening again
oh look at that bird
look at the look at the coffee there he
is looks like she wants us to join her
for breakfast
perhaps this town's finally starting to
warm up to us
ah you still got the smile
wow i love him look at that oh they
nailed it
she's welcoming us with open arms
she's even willing to share that tasty
morsel with us
what an honor
hurry up and chow down mister unless you
like your breakfast stale
what an amazing place i've been on top
of the moon since the moment i got here
top of the moon huh
and the name of this wonderful town
liqari
sounds like french to me but what does
it mean
it's clearly the same voice actor but uh
it just sounds a little different yeah
if you know what i mean
if you want to know about the town you'd
better ask the concierge
oh if it's just because it's gotten
older or if it's like an inflection
thing
he sounds like someone who thought he
was doing a one-off video game and
didn't think he'd ever get called back
to do another one
and he was told to sound like he used to
and he didn't expect to have to ever
call that up again
did you hear that zach he's a true
professional
yeah imagine being being that guy
yeah and getting the phone call being
like i'm sorry what
deadly premonition two please don't ask
me it's a name i haven't
heard in so long
never thought the fbi would ever come
out to a little old town like us
i do work for the fbi but i didn't come
here for an investigation
i just happened to stop by he looks like
he's like bulked up he's looks
kind of beefy never thought that yeah
either and it was a 16 year old kid
now i tell you this country's seen
better days
what you reckon mister
zach he's definitely a professional but
it seems like he's also a bit late
he's still with an ear shot everywhere
i think he's hitting on me folks say the
killer used an
axe hell of an old-fashioned choice if
you ask me
what actually chef david if you don't
mind
i'd like to ask you a few questions
about the incident
i'd like to ask you your favorite choice
of murder weapon
fbi i only heard what i heard
but seeing as you fixing the grill me i
can tell you what i know
please do i appreciate it like split
second that he did the smile
uh i guess i'm just going over tell me
about the kelly clarkson house
uh what do you know about the victim you
said the victim was a 16 year old
did you know her well sure i reckon the
whole town did
meaning she's lisa clarkson
the little grandbaby of the clarkson
family
the clarkson family that's right
you ain't seen a sign on your way in
here
the one above that huge cold storage
complex
should have had a dragonfly on you
anyway
that's the clarkson family up the volume
got hmm they all most of them
and okay from the sugar plant stepped
away from this mic for that part
yeah i reckon they got a stake in just
about everything
they even owned the water tower on the
edge of town you know i feel bad that
york isn't offering him like a seat
and they still support it right
yeah yeah what do you know about the
clarkson's house
now i ain't got nothing bad to say
but i'm gonna talk straight to you you
best deal clear that place
that family ain't just some gang they're
a whole different kind of beast
they folks with real power
remnants of the good old boys who shaped
america in the early days
especially the head of the family pj
clarkson he's the kind of monster who
goes around
eating other monsters huh and i'm sure
he's on edge now with his granddaughter
getting murdered and all
so don't go barging in with that shiny
fbi
badge of yours and think you'll be safe
or nothing things are different down
here
so if you plan on sticking around you
best remember that
i see now keep that in mind
what's local enforcement law enforcement
investigating the case
that's fair
that's also how i feel about local law
enforcement big save
that's the mood now i told you this
ain't no city
we in the bonafide boom dogs here
are we this is a very nice looking place
to break up fights and keep folks from
killing each other when they piss
you off they sit down and talk it out
with your heart to heart
and when that don't work they just beat
your ass
that's the deep south for you this
murder ain't like that
though a little kid got killed
a weird way like something on the tv
show or a video game sheriff's
department ain't never seen nothing like
this
live and let die angel heart and the
pelican brief
right nine out of ten people will name
those titles when you ask them to think
about
he's just listing off film set in new
orleans
due to my line of work i have a tendency
to think deeply about what feels real
and what doesn't
what's the point cat people
that's my point cat people there are too
many of them 1982
directed by paul schrader the crowning
achievement of nastasia kinski the
ultimate muse of the 80s the most vital
element of that movie is the reality it
depicts
leopards who turn into humans have
intercourse
with humans and turn back into leopards
sounds like a movie i need to see they
can only turn back into humans again
if they mutilate their lovers i was
awestruck by the sheer reality of it all
i wonder understand i'm talking about if
that might have been like an influence
on the good life
at all because it sounds like it's like
half the setup of what that game was the
world of cat people for myself
is that game still happening it is but
it's more of like an animal crossing
thing
i think that's why i decided oh
interesting
uh okay that is also how i
respond to that another vital element of
cat people
is the presence of malcolm mcdowell i
was going to say
mac mcdowell is top tier malcolm
mcdowell from blue thunder
oh talk about it masterpiece
i don't know blue thunder is the first
thing i would go to when i think of
malcolm mcdowell but you know what
that's
you doing george you know listen
carefully david
only an amateur would call a clockwork
[Laughter]
this is sweary getting out all his spicy
tastes real though
it's the best movies are cat people move
on
what period
were you gonna say clockwork orange
that's the truth
well i mean i feel like that's the
obvious one right but like
whatever you say but you know what i
guess york put me in my place
i guess i'm just an amateur period again
never mind don't worry about it yeah
what what did we ask you about original
important parts
something about new orleans oh geez
anyway tell me more about the murder
something from a tv show what exactly do
you mean what do you know
hey mister why do you look so excited
huh
like a kid asking grandma to read them a
fairy tale
i just can't seem to keep myself away
from young women
who died in bizarre ways it's a real
problem not something
you should ever say a loud york yes same
well i ain't seen it with my own eyes
but folks say they found the body
hanging under a bridge on the bayou
and under that bridge there was some
kind of
altar an altar
like something they use in black magic
something horrible
voodoo nah
what nothing like that just a weird
altar that's all
what oh and the body was
all cut up in pieces scattered around
the halter like
so she was sacrificed that's what the
fella who discovered us said yeah
bingo zach what this case has got our
names
all over it again
not the best their names aren't all over
it
by the way you seen the car in the
parking lot
how'd you get all the way out here huh
don't tell me you walked
well that's a very good question chef
david
you've got a sharp eye it's true that i
didn't
hope he crashed his car in the woods
outside of town again do you know why
because i don't trust her parking lot
can't say i do
because it was stolen huh oh
but you with the fbi right
even fbi cars can be stolen it could
happen
after you park your car on the side of
the road and go off to do some legwork
when you're eating lunch when you're
watching a movie when you're asleep at
night
when you're buying cigarettes at the
local soup all the time your car
can be stolen anywhere that's precisely
what it means to be an fbi agent
is that what it means to me it doesn't
it doesn't though you're that's not what
it means to be an fbi agent
categorically i'm willing to say
but no need to worry i already reported
it to the local authorities
and i've also but we just talked about
how they don't do anything
another mode want to hear the details oh
it's that sick car they were talking
about not
really i do i'll listen if you want me
to
it's that big strong mysterious handsome
car yourself
oh no but that was in the present
after i finished my work in houston i
flew to new orleans
then i rented a car at the airport
whenever i visit the west coast i always
rent a convertible
especially in california but now i'm in
hot and sticky louisiana
so i decided on a brand new
hybrid car with a fully equipped air
conditioning system
a hybrid car oh yes they're marvelous
vehicles utterly defy everything you
think you know
marvelous in the year 2005 it feels like
we
finally entered the 21st century stomp
down on the gas all you want
the engine won't make a sound it's
silent
at first i felt like the landscape was
moving past me on its own
give it a few more years and i'm sure
we'll start seeing cars that run
purely on electricity who knows
in a decade or so electric sports cars
may end up lining the parking lots of
silicon valley
i can see it now it's the world of the
last star fighter
1984.
[Laughter]
thanks eric it's famous for being the
first film to utilize realistic cg
but i couldn't care less about that i
care about the hybrid cars
i was mesmerized by the beautifully
refined mech designs
it even made me wish that i could be is
york like a like a
like a godzilla mech animation
spacecraft no other sci-fi
he's gotta be he had so uh yeah where
joe he definitely has to be
sorry i got off topic i noticed it was
missing oh that was a good
keep going walked out of the diner
incidentally this diner was located at
the entrance to a small town just south
off the i-10
i went out to get back in it but my
hybrid car was nowhere to be found
i remembered exactly where i parked it
right between a blue pickup truck and a
hedgerow
but when i came back from lunch it had
completely vanished
in short someone stole it cool
someone stole your car and in its place
they left me this
ah yeah that's it
upgrades a skateboard
yes a skateboard sliding my lunch into
my stomach
someone is busy replacing my brand new
hybrid car
with a wooden board attached to four
why do you look so surprised no i
couldn't ride the board very well at
first
but by the time i hit the three mile
mark i'd more or less gotten the hang of
it
by the 10 mile mark i'd even learned to
do a few trips
if you're imagining like driving down
the highway and you just see
a man skateboarding doing uh
in in like a [ __ ] dude
it was a journey of selfies yeah just
kick flipping his way across
oh not even i knew i had this latent
talent
sleeping
god i love york so much i missed
i'm so happy he's back it's supposed to
get over 95
today watch out you don't go getting
heatstroke
felice clarkson case needs us don't you
think so zack
the cat people are what guided us to new
orleans
we should be thanking malcolm mcdowell
once we get home let's watch blue
thunder again
sure i'm already looking forward to it
aren't you zack
zack the searing light
these scents yeah
it's the deep south
you got a fabulous breakfast you're the
world's greatest
eat any of it
uh wait mister you didn't take us it's
still all there
yeah well the tea was thank you david
for calling him out on his [ __ ]
but i'd prefer coffee next okay what
would a morning be without coffee
[Music]
he had a whole pineapple there too i was
wondering what the pineapple is about
you know we'll never figure out
you'll never know
would would this be maybe whoa
look at his oh look at how sh yeah she
is
something else how big
is his broadest shoulders are
[Music]
is that a continental breakfast look at
that pie
compliment jesus it's a huge pie
oh damn man
those breads are cheeses sausages good
good pizza huh
my favorite breakfast of the champions
i'm gonna go back to york's room all
right
[Music]
so are these pajamas i would assume so
yeah they look like pajamas
i do like this hotel jam
you know this is a cool hotel and all
but i missed paulie already oh polly
polly on her giant table look at the
okay no one there is it just me or
something about
the the size of everything and
the speed at which he's running versus
the animation
it doesn't it doesn't line up
he's it's fine
he's what was get into a fight stance
help
[Music]
i feel like i've seen that punch
animation before
oh oh the red room
oh it's still here oh hey
heck yeah uh all right let's let's go to
our room
yeah yeah yeah i hope he has a bunch of
suits to pick up from
oh yeah and i'm never gonna
are we gonna shave him are we not gonna
shave him uh we gotta not shave him if
we
if that's a thing yeah i
bearded york is the best york and i
can't
hear otherwise oh
it's the music looking
looking good san rouge
chasing it all over america
but
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's about time we ordered a new
briefcase
yes i know this one when life is
beautiful happens oh god
seen too much this holes from the
shootout
they've got to be holding it out for a
special moment stains from miami
uh miami now that was a fascinating case
billy our perp cut his own torso right
into
even with the help of the drugs a feet
like that still requires incredible
mental fortitude
i was so impressed forgot i'd left my
briefcase on the floor
same floor his blood gushed out onto
is that billy's blood
i know zach i know now isn't the time
for a trip down memory lane
i just want to hear your like york's
voice actor just go off on tangents
like i'm fine with that an emergent drug
that's been on the rise in four southern
states
personally i think it originated right
here in louisiana
okay clarkson's murder must be connected
to it somehow
so we got drugs
her body was found beneath a bridge over
the bayou
along with a strange altar
and he seems to be more fearsome than
your average gangster
i doubt he'll be willing to cooperate
with any law enforcement zack
this is a cool way to structure this
yeah it's
it's actually yeah it stays on the wall
that's unique
i love thinking about that movie we
stopped to see on our way here zach the
island
oh which one directed by michael bay
michael bay
i like how he says 2005 he's in the year
2005.
you don't need to yeah for a movie being
shown at a yeah
complex it was surprisingly artistic
an experimental setting mixed with
hard-hitting drama
it was art house sci-fi ah i wouldn't go
that far
[Music]
that director is going to change the
look york's just dropping
spicy takes everywhere that michael bay
he's going to change the history of art
house
the the best the best part of it is this
is all made
my favorite art house film transformers
this is another special film that's
setting a new standard just like
star wars and blue runner did star wars
and plane runner
so are they really just leaning into the
idea that york has like
whack taste in movies this is
so i i love that you may be whatever
someone
talks about a new word that will soon be
deadly premonition
it seems like it just blew up all the
things that people say first
so you got this fbi detective who really
loves movies and you get movie trivia
when you're driving
so what if he just says movie trivia
like every every two minutes
yes in normal conversation what if he
talks about cat people
whole new genre while he's gathering
information he is putting a lot of stock
into the island
a movie that nobody remembers
like why york remembers it i'm okay
like so up into this point island movies
i sure like the sound of that that's
what we call them now
hey ben ben you see that lady is an
island movie
you know i love it's my favorite next to
this the strand genre of games the
island genre of movies
uh you know what makes this whole
situation even better though
is this is uh zak recounting all of this
to the people who are talking to him in
the future
so he's actually just telling them about
the [ __ ] movie things that he's
talking about
oh that's all over again
not not in his room alone but now making
ex
people actually what what hello
it's a it's room exactly excuse me
so feel like a murder happened in here
maybe we've got an altar already set up
the phone's for you
[Music]
so it looks like you can go into the
pilot yeah let's check out more of that
uh
i've assumed that all the trivia you
know it's like weird it's weird trivia
he has weird taste in movies i just
assumed that was like
sweary's actual taste in movies
but well i don't th that whole thing
about the island makes me really
question that
i'm very satisfied with the decorations
and the size of this closet
it's it's a 2020 opinion being pushed
back into a game that's set in
but like i guess maybe maybe he really
liked it back in 2005 and actually
thought it would become a big deal and
then it didn't
so he felt like he needed to let people
know
i'm very curious i want to talk to story
about movies now
we need to bring swirly in to talk about
film
oh that's a good looking outfit yep okay
dry cleaning that's still upside down
that mechanic yeah
rubber bullets rubber bullets
it's a lot of rubber bullets first aid
kit mr alligator
what does that mean
[Music]
i don't know cola
what it says coke but with a different
font
oh lollipops are still here weird
you could totally still shave flip we're
growing it out
i'm calling it no one can stop us
due to the nature you can take a shower
too we've had to stay at hotels all over
america
but zach do you know what i hate most
about living out of a hotel
it shout pressure the shower was
invented so that human beings could
quickly bathe in large quantities of
water correct
yet there are far too many hotels in our
nation that have showers with
embarrassingly weak
water pressure it's an outrage yeah
that's fair
and i'll keep tooting my horn about this
every chance
i will tell everyone everyone needs to
know how i feel about water pressure in
hotels see what i like about hotels is
actually the bath
because i don't really like take baths
that often i feel like if i'm in a
really fancy hotel that's like prime
opportunity to take advantage of the
bathtub
yeah you don't even have to clean that
stuff someone else has to
it's an opportunity
oh boy
what if we actually have to check
everything before we go to the door i
think we're good
oh okay hello
hey there more songs are back oh that's
the chef
chef what are you talking about
sir what i'm the concierge of david
i just heard from our chef that you wish
to learn the meaning behind our town's
name
yes i've gathered that lucares is he
gonna be
every person in this hotel
why yes sir of course it does i kind of
really hope
all names have meanings would you like
to know what this one means
yes i would jolly good sir
then allow me to explain jolly good
means square in french ah
and that's it
that's it oh yes
that's it perfect do take time to square
the town map in the lobby if it fancies
you
it's beautiful it doesn't look like a
dog this time around
i'm sure you'll understand once you see
it
now please excuse me sir if you ever
need
anything please don't hesitate to ask
this man changed his outfit and
personality
came up just telling tom
translation did you see that zach
the square that was clearly david not a
twin
not a split personality just the work of
a true professional
it's bizarre but i can understand it
remember what they say the job makes the
man
sure yeah i'm down
answer the door clear
ding i'll get to check the map now
oh never mind we don't get to check the
map yet
[Music]
this is going to be me humming along
with the music a whole bunch i need to i
need to stop
myself right now
do you feel that zach
dozens of people ever see
a faint scent of tobacco baked into
these walls for over a century
now that's what i call a hotel
hell yeah zach can you see him
his fashion sense is beyond me but he
appears to be a gentleman
perhaps we should talk to him
is that moving york that's a painting
my dude
york
[Music]
uh nice tie
it's not a did you buy it here painting
what
it's been a long time since someone
spoke to me
no one these days okay tries to see me
excuse me they can see what's far in the
distance but are blind to what's in
front of them
no what maybe they're only pretending
not to see
that's what civilized society does to
people
exactly well we live in a society ben
since mankind we do
clearly speed
zoomed away from what this is a mirror
right
i don't see a picture behind it i don't
know i don't know what's happening
anymore
as for me just call me
[Music]
title given to a leader in a certain
religion
is that what you are
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
the oracle
put on your religion hat sack here we go
in the shrine of hunger
find the flying serpent in the ambiguous
zero
dance with the flying serpent and you
will glitch the other world
ten maidens oh yokotaro you and your
quotes
got it but what do you mean by
otherworld
follow the oracle
okay okay so it was a different type of
painting zach did you hear all that
looks like we've already taken our first
step into
chaos yeah what is happening
is our duty we need to accept the chaos
let it inside then carefully dismantle
it piece by piece
okay after we've put all the pieces back
into their rightful places
the truth will reveal itself
let's capture the truth and present it
with a shiny pair of silver bracelets
zach
take it out on a nice date
yeah yeah show it a real good time
oh okay
that buffalo yeah does that have
anything to tell us their perfect symbol
of the human condition
hunting trophies
and it's a buffalo hunting trophy now
that's a surprise
i've seen several trophies made out of
human skin but
never a buffaloes
looking at him brings out this strange
feeling from within me
yes the very same feeling i got when
watching a certain film from 1984
directed by peter hiams 2010
the last scene in that film filled me
with such a sublime majestic feeling
it was filled with everything that was
missing from the finale of 2001 a space
odyssey
just talking about it makes me want to
watch it again
watch it once we get home i promise i'm
telling you they're
they're doubling down on his like weird
tasted movies
their their movie stack is gonna be huge
by the time they get done with this and
get home
[Music]
oh dracula
[Music]
the hotel is called casa pineapple
so that's why you got the pineapple on
the table
it's a brand thing
i wish there were more pineapple
decorations
drink good vending
oh hey the prices are actually uh normal
this time
oh that's unfortunate oh root beer
let's buy some repair hell yeah
i bet i bet york really likes
root beer what
a vending machine donut huh why not
it's a finely made donut it'll fill you
up well
okay i'm trying yep i'm trying to find
our straight button oh god
i was about to say i wonder if there's a
sprint button but
oh i love kind of the weird distortion
on the music yeah that was weird
oh here we go yeah oh heroin
our boys got some pickup and going i'm
looking
i love it
she's got stamina though that's the
thing oh bathrooms
oh no whether it's a restaurant or was
this the right bathroom the key i think
you're charming your customers
yeah there's urinals i would assume it
is okay
i'm sure you feel the same i was really
worried that york was gonna be like ah
we're in the wrong bathroom this is the
kind of bathroom a person can really get
excited about
is it just take that out of context put
it somewhere
the one we saw in that drugstore it's
perfect austin
what is just a bathroom the art piece on
display in there utilized the natural
curves of human ribs in such a
novel way was truly brilliant
[Music]
that's exactly what i was thinking this
is the worst bathroom i've ever seen you
know what's wild
uh flippin this game has real-time
reflections in it you know what game
didn't
final fantasy 7 remake so what i'm
saying is deadly premonition two
is better than final fantasy vii remake
yeah i think i got that right
that retracing attack you know yeah yeah
god can you imagine modding deadly
premonition with ray tracing
i'd love to see it all right let's check
this map
yeah let's let's see ah zack it's a
square
lucario um zack this is lucari
i think i'm finally starting to
understand what our concierge was trying
to say
you can tell this town was built by a
very methodical person
no wait maybe they just didn't care and
that's why it ended up this way
it's just another symbol of my kind
that's the opposite
bring the music
clear okay we have the map now
zach what did you think of hoongan's
oracle
despite all the dramatic build up it's
little more than a childish riddle
heartwarming really exactly the kind of
feeling one gets from the good
old-fashioned countryside
[Music]
now let's start oracle's downstairs
oracle gave us a place and an app uh we
need to go to the shrine
of hunger and fell ten maidens now where
in this town can one satiate poor hunger
the shrine of hunger is definitely the
diner and the ten
things that need to be knocked down the
diner simple
right alexis's diner and it's got a
bowling motif
oh it does have a bully motif knock the
means
down fall them down go to the place oh
oh dude it's not a bowling motif i think
it's an actual bowling alley
oh never mind diner and lane
there you go oh man maybe even both at
the same time
because when i think bowling i think
cajun cuisine
be i've seen weirder mashups i'm gonna
be honest
how do you eat cajun cuisine while
bowling at the same time
a pro i feel like you could be urged on
by the
the spices to do better at bowling it
just seems very messy
yeah could it be a contrail or
perhaps a dragon i'm sure we'll find out
i hope it's a dragon
first let's just figure out where we
need to go
do you know what the ambiguous zero
represents zero is usually treated as a
base number
but under what conditions would a base
number be ambiguous
the answer is temperature
zero degrees fahrenheit is minus 17.7
degrees celsius
and zero degrees celsius fahrenheit
you'd be hard pressed to find a more
ambiguous zero than that
the question is does our zero refer to
celsius
food let's think delivery place might
have uh
which measurement system the place to
keep the stuff refrigerated and cool
okay we use fahrenheit
i'm leaning towards graveyard but more
importantly i'm leaning towards the
food delivery style let's try food
delivery this is cold
storage warehouse nailed it
even with this blazing sun in the sky
they can easily keep the temperature
below freezing
the temperature below freezing exactly
you knew the answer from the very start
didn't you
i can't believe we're solving all these
these problems oracle decryption but
yeah fifteen dollars for being smart
and how about you know how many good
donuts we can get a character
his oracles may end up determining how
much time we spend in this town
oh
what is happening smoke free hotel
if you're dying to smoke head out the
entrance and you'll find a smoking area
in the rear parking lot
don't tell me what's going on
good friends oh concierge and the chef
we work at the same place yeah
but uh i can't really say whether we're
good friends with each other
we're all professionals though nothing
more nothing less
what that's right
i'm really hoping for like uh like a
grim fandango type of reveal
for this this is all his charm
so we're gonna walk out the front door
and all three of them are gonna pop out
and be like what was with that guy
okay i'll play by your rules
okay first get a strike is your object
hold on so york is york has shown up
to figure out what's happening with a
murder by happenstance
and he is then talked to by a picture on
the wall
who gives him a riddle to tell him to go
to a cajun food place in bowling alley
in a place that's really cold and that's
just his like way of doing it
yeah i mean can you really question his
methods
no i mean the results surely will will
happen
yeah i know we're gonna see it i think
we'll have to find out
uh next time yeah
[Music]